recruitment isn't what everyone thinks
it is they think oh I just find people
jobs but it's so much more than that in
many places it's the sales it's building
relationships you probably say about 70
percent of the job market are people who
jump around and expect a lot but then
you get that 30 people who they're
accountable for their own success
that type of person is the type of
person I find is truly successful in
recruitment welcome back to another
episode of the recruitment mentors
podcast I'm your host Hisham azuz and in
today's episode I was joined by Susanna
Gray Jones who has worked within
education recruitment for over a decade
where she took herself as a trainee all
the way to senior manager and divisional
manager level and more recently she's
been on her own entrepreneurial Journey
where over the last 18 months to two
years she's been building her own right
to rec business we discussed mindset to
what good prospecting looks like to what
is really common amongst top performers
within the recruitment industry advice
for any of you who may be considering a
career move within recruitment what to
look for if you're not quite getting
what you hoped for in your current
environment how to navigate that and ask
the right questions and so much more
enjoy the episode welcome to the podcast
Susanna how are we I'm so good I love
being in London
so for those that will be watching uh
but if you're listening in a new space
today so this is only the first person
joining me in the new podcast Studio
that we're going to be using to record
so I'm excited to have a good
conversation about all things
recruitment in in this new space
um so we will start with uh the the
million pound question but I guess just
before we do I wanted to give people
listening uh just a bit of background
and context to your journey but we're
going to get into it so you've been in
recruitment since 2008
uh a lot of that time has been within
education recruitment
but for the last 18 months coming up to
two years you've been building your own
rhetoric business
for the first three years of your
recruitment career you're very much
focused on uh yourself individual
contributor but then uh went into
leadership and before you left education
recruitment uh was a sales director for
the business that you work for so I
think today uh definitely going to talk
about how to be successful in
educational recruitment the things that
you learn leadership but then also I
think a lot of people do think about
doing rhetoric probably think it's
easier than it is so definitely uh
curious to find out what your journey
has been what you've learned challenges
and also yeah just just the insights
that you've taken from speaking to to
recruiters
um every day so let me answer the
million pound question then because I'm
sure you've had to really think about
this when hiring for your for your
clients so in in your opinion what
characteristics and traits really make
up a successful recruiter in today's
market do you think yeah that is the
question that everyone's asking isn't it
it's um what is a good recruiter so
first of all I've learned along the way
I've made some mistakes by recruiting
the wrong people very early in my career
and recruiting the wrong person can be
disastrous for an organization
um a recruitment isn't what everyone
thinks it is people go into it and they
think it's going to be something
completely different they think oh I
just find people jobs but it's so much
more than that in many places it's it
sales it's building relationships it's
compliance there's so many different
aspects to it so to answer your question
I would say first of all
humility
and sounds really obvious but not many
people have humility these days there's
quite a few people who expect quite a
lot and accountability would be a huge
one
um but also the ability to read people
and build relationships and listen
don't you hate it like training they
always talk about listen like it's
really obvious but actually it's really
hard because the human beings we're
often trying to think about what that
person's gonna say when if you were
talking to me I might be thinking what
am I going to say next what am I going
to say next how many times are we
engaged in a conversation with someone
and we're actually thinking about what
we're gonna say opposed to actually
engaging what they're saying so I think
the ability to listen humility and to
build relationships yeah listen I'm
always trying to improve on my listening
skills it's exactly what you said quick
question on that then
I'm definitely hearing this a lot in
terms of the recruitment ages that I
speak to around
accountability humility how how have you
ended up looking for
humility accountability or testing that
in yeah the the job that you do now or
maybe how did you look for that when you
was hiring people in educational
recruitment like how did you test those
things I think there's a big clue in how
people speak about their experiences and
this doesn't just relate director I
think it relates to any kind of
recruitment
when people reflect on previous
experiences in previous jobs they either
tell themselves
that they learned from a bad experience
or they blame someone else and I think
there's two types of people there's one
type of person who's like
oh the environment was just wrong they
treated me like rubbish and it's just
not fair and I don't want to work there
anymore and they jump around and you see
them everywhere okay lots of these I'd
probably say about 70 percent of the
chop Market of people who jump around
and expect a lot but then you get that
30 people who are accountability they're
accountable for their own success
they look at themselves and they've they
think what could I have done differently
and they have that ability to
self-reflect that type of person is a
type of person who's always learning is
the type of person I find is truly
successful in recruitment yeah so
asking them to share about talk about
their experiences and and like you said
looking for
clues of people saying it was their
fault or pointing the finger rather than
going I could have done this better yeah
definitely there's some brilliant
questions out there you know like what
would you say is the best thing about
managing you everyone can answer that
because we sell ourselves right we're
recruiters but what is the hardest thing
about managing you well tell me about a
really bad day and then they'll talk to
you candidate ghosted me they didn't
turn up this really awful thing happened
and then client was angry with me then
did they turn it into a positive or do
they just delve into the negativity like
how did they lift themselves up a lot of
people are talking about bounce of
backability like the ability to bounce
back from a really bad situation
yeah I love that
so let's talk about this uh educational
recruitment Journey so start in 2008
um from what what I saw worked for a big
recruitment business and then joined
another business which you ended up
working for was it for like 10 years or
something like that yeah so yeah now to
University the Wilder oyster right
um I everything aspect of my life you
know I'd have new group boyfriends every
six months I've had I was changing jobs
like I think I had two jobs within a
year I was like do you know what like I
don't know but you know didn't really
have a plan was just happy to be in
London doing my thing and then I found
this really great company that just
believed in me and really nurtured me I
was never an administrator there were a
lot of people in sales you say you've
got like people who are very adaptable
and salesy and people great kind of
crossing the t's and dotting the eyes I
was never one of those people I was
always about the sales the quick kind of
very very kind of almost patient nosy
which I think actually really good
qualities for a recruiter and but they
recognize that you know I'm I'm dyslexic
I've got dyspraxia they didn't bring me
down for the fact that
maybe I was a bit scatty they looked at
what I was doing well and supported me
with those things and because of that I
found my home
and had I not found that who knows I
might not be in recruitment today I
think I truly believe that if people can
find the right environment then they can
build their career and many people leave
recruitment
unnecessarily because they've had a bad
experience they think it's something
it's not but if you can find that right
environment it can change your life and
it did for me how did I make you feel
then to you've obviously had experiences
where you didn't feel supported included
empowered is that something you felt
quite quickly in the interview process
is it something that you felt quite
earlier like how how did they make you
feel like that
I think it's that genocide choir isn't
it you you come to an interview and it's
like
it's when you meet someone you know you
just kind of I like your Vibe like it's
kind of you just kind of you connect
you're speaking the same language you
know you talk about love languages a lot
don't they like people have different
ways of expressing
um themselves when they like it's the
same with employment you have different
languages of how you you grow and I
think it's not about my company where
access we're a better company than
anywhere else obviously they were for me
but I think it's finding the right place
for you and your personality and
yeah they were very accepting of
different types of people
let's just I just let's just talk about
this for a sec
so with that I think this will be
helpful for people
there'll probably be a lot of people
listening to this that don't feel like
in the current environment they're in
they are
empowered
um included in the things that you've
described so I guess just to get a bit
more practical there because you're now
helping recruiters
like if you've maybe recognized that the
environment that you're in isn't an
environment that you think is getting
the best out of you
obviously there's got to be an element
of accountability in there as we said
but what what can I what can I actually
do to have a better chance of of finding
that you know because I don't know I
understand what you're saying but should
I be asking the right questions what
should I be looking like what should I
like what my non-negotiables I look for
when I go in there sort of into your
environment I don't know if there's
anything more practical there that could
help people
um yeah just actually really apply it in
those types of environments to feel more
confident that they're going to be in
the business that is right for them if
they're not thinking they're in the
right business for them at the moment
yeah I mean the first thing I would say
is as human beings we have this will to
connect with people right so the first
thing I would say is the don't the
natural thing to do is when you don't
feel valued or you feel like the
environment isn't quite right for you
the natural thing and we see it
everywhere is to go to my colleague and
say over lunch let's go and have lunch
or I feel really undervalued
and oh my gosh misery loves a friend and
it builds and it creates it doesn't make
you feel any better and we all see it in
every organization people grew together
and they have a moment and then it
doesn't get any better
people look for signs they get a bit
paranoid about the workplace I think the
first thing you can do is deal with it
head-on without speaking to your
colleague about it because it might not
be a problem for them and that's been a
huge thing for me growing in my career
is not getting involved in the
negativity that happens in the offices
and being kind and pleasant to everyone
but professional my path is my path I'm
not going to get involved in the
whinging which you have in every
workplace so the first thing I would say
find a boss that you can speak to
do they listen do they understand you
because it might be that they do when
they fix it straight away and that is
what I say to many recruiters that I
speak to I say speak to your boss first
you feel undervalued not paying you
enough
what have you done to speak to them
because I'm not going to represent them
if I think they'll be better off where
they are by just having a simple
conversation I'm not that type of
recruiter I'm not just after a quick fee
I'd rather that they had I actually
coached them for having that
conversation I make no money out to them
but I've helped them
be happier in their own workplace and
for me that is what it's about sometimes
just empowering people to speak to their
bosses if they can't speak to their boss
and they still feel undervalued and
there's a culture difficulty then you
know we go on our journey but I always
first of all we'll try and say speak to
them and you'll be surprised often we
don't like being confrontational with
our bosses if we respect them and
sometimes that's exactly what you need
to do but do in the right way
yeah that's that's yeah difficult
conversations right yeah but you have to
have them and then and then just just to
sort of finalize that if I've had that
conversation
felt like they didn't listen felt like
you know what I've done my part
I've taken accountability I've said look
this is where I feel like I need more
help or where I'm not being empowered or
valued things don't change
what what's then the advice in terms of
like when you're then sitting in front
of potential employers
what is the Practical advice in yeah
really trying to have the best chance of
them uh having the next company to be
the right fit and not the things that
you've experienced I think that's what
will be helpful for people because the
way that you described your connection
with the company that you ended up
working for over a decade didn't it
sounded quite untangle I don't know
there's sort of untangibles in there it
just felt right or whatever so I don't
know if there's anything you can then
add in okay I've had that conversation
now I want to make sure I want to commit
myself to recruitment I want to make
sure that the next company is the
company where I can thrive in I'm
supported
um what is it that I have to ask what is
it that I have to find out uh before I
accept a job offer with a company and
um I'm made to feel confident that this
could be the better environment for me I
love that question
um and I think one of the main things
would be to
use it as a discovery so often in
interviews we just want to impress we
want to be accepted that we forget to
do our own Discovery write down what are
the 10 most important values to me in
this company and ask them for example
right so for example if I think that I
want to go somewhere where I can learn
and really progress I will say what
could that look like for someone like me
and what would you need to see from me
to get to that point and in what
situation might that not happen so that
you're prepared for you know everyone
talks about broken promises I was
promised this in three years and it
didn't happen to ask them you know what
when might this not happen what would
you need to see
um can you give me examples of people
who've taken this journey and ask them
what do people say that's great about
your company what do people say that's
not so great like and they'll probably
be honest with you and there is always
going to be bad press about every
company out there so meet the people
make up your own minds and you know get
as many examples as you can get stories
you know I love that exercise of writing
down the things that are really
important to you
so let's talk about your own recruitment
career and then we'll talk about uh some
of the things you've learned in the last
18 months or so but I guess let's just
start with from my own experience uh
obviously interviewing people like
Steffy we've had on the podcast working
a bit with her business
educational recruitment from what I
understand particularly on on the temp
side may be a bit more similar to what I
experienced when I was a permanent
recruiter but it's just very nuanced and
very uh what am I trying to say just the
other note like various like if you're
on a successful education recruiter
I feel like that could potentially be
very different for other Industries I
know you might be able to see something
different there but it's very fast paced
can also potentially be quite
transactional in certain environments so
I guess I wanted to to start with like
from your perspective
what are the the principles to being a
successful education recruiter like
let's start there from from your own
Journey yeah well first of all
you can get by in any recruitment role
being a b recruiter being an okay
recruiter but my advice would be it's
not worth it like if you're going to be
in recruitment you've got to be an a
now for example I would say
try and avoid being transactional
now what I mean by that is let's say for
example you're talking about a role that
you're interested in but then you've
decided actually no Suzanne I don't want
to go to the interview I'm happy where I
am
I might know that this would be a much
better fit for you I might see that
blind spot I might be perfect in their
organization now what I don't want to do
is I don't want to push you but I want
to persuade you to at least have a chat
so an a great recruiter is someone who
knows that blind spot
can influence that candidate in their
best interest not yours and make them
realize that it's in their best interest
and not yours so to be a top education
recruiter is to avoid being
transactional is to always think about
why that person be good for that setting
and to tell them why and to make it more
about them and make it more of a jigsaw
to make sure the right pieces go in the
right place as opposed to someone is a
teacher that just send them there like
what kind of teacher do you like who
works well here this is why I think this
person would work well there so stop
being a recruitment
recruited transactional person be a
consultant bring back the Consulting to
recruit team because there are a lot of
people who aren't Consulting anymore and
I think it's really important that
remember you are there to consult not
just to transact
so don't be transactional yeah what else
did the the rule a a recruiters top
performers and educational recruitment
do really well do you think I think care
communication right look at your
LinkedIn probably get hundreds of
messages every week
and emails and my opinion is there's a
place for email Some people prefer
emails but a robot can email a robot can
message bring the personality into it
pick up the phone and it sounds very old
school and that whole smile and dial
thing but honestly even if you're having
a bad day pick up the phone because
people would rather hear a voice and
we've got so much to our disposal these
days we've got video messages we've got
Zoom build the build the relationships
with people when you're recruiting so
and those will last forever you might
not have something for that candidate
right now but the fact that you took
time they will remember your service and
they'll build that relationship they'll
come back to you they'll refer people
that is what a good refrigerator is
someone who's not just in it for the
quick transaction quick deal but someone
who really cares about that person and
improving their life
hmm
and you were you as a temp recruiter
right yes
yes it was I was so so at the peak like
how many people did do you have I'm
assumed is it how many like attempts you
had in your book or how many I don't
know how what the correct terminology
would be for you to how many Runners you
had about how many teachers you had out
probably about 30 to 60 a week yeah
um and that was a lot because you're
thinking like the changes the sickness
all of that I would be I don't know how
I did it I really entered theater as
well I'd be doing shows in the evening
and like picking up the phone in the
interval just like trying to fill the
role for the next day it's full on temp
but the days go really quickly it's
really exciting
um if you're the type of person who was
just fascinated by people and you want
to know if they're going to work out and
you want to match them in like
you you guess it and then it does work
and it doesn't work then you'll love it
like if you if you get bored easily go
into a temp environment
just so full on what so let's talk about
because again I'm sure we would have
seen this a lot particularly in
leadership what what were the the common
stumbling blocks or common obstacles
that Recruiters in that environment temp
magritters would often maybe Keep
Falling on
um keep on them themselves hitting that
would potentially hold them back or not
enable them quite to get to where they
could what were the constant challenges
that maybe you had to help people break
through and work for in that type of
environment yeah I think the bounce back
ability the resilience because someone's
going to let you down
but the sales okay everyone's like it's
not sales it is I really believe it is
but maybe take away sales because people
think of car sales they think of like
dishonest kind of like just trying to
get something
think about influencing people and it
really is influencing people hey
everyone a real quick one from me this
podcast would not be possible without
our amazing podcast Partners Vin cherry
and Source breaker because you listen to
this podcast you're able to get your
hands on exclusive savings on both of
these award-winning products if you're a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincere who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with Source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
Source breaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products you've
got to have a pipeline you can't
everyone wants to be an account manager
these days everyone's like I just want
to manage accounts much easier because
our brains have the fight-or-flight that
it goes to the amygdala we're calling
someone up do you want to work with me
and they say no it hurts us right and
that's normal it comes from the cavemen
times the fighter flight you know just
want to keep with our tribe we've got to
stay alive all of that and our brain's
going to kick kind of fear when we get
rejection but the minute that people get
over that and they realize do you know
what just four or five a day I'm gonna
try and call some new clients then when
all the recruitment's dried up you'll
still have stuff coming through the pipe
and too many recruiters they rely on the
incoming stuff they forget to do the BD
and then they wonder why two months in I
was really busy
why is it quiet now I've got new clients
and then they want to leave or they've
got a manager telling them to get on the
phone and no one wants to get on the
phone when you're told to get on the
phone and make sales calls and that was
my biggest mistake as a manager when I
first started I was like do sales calls
let's do sales calls woohoo and
everyone's like really and I never asked
them why they didn't want to make the
sales calls we never explored that
that was my biggest lesson as a manager
I think because I was so task orientated
like make the calls make the calls no
one wants it's like going to the gym the
PT's like do another press up like you
know but it's why I don't even do the
press-ups talk about the fear it's real
talk about how you give them stories
give them inspirational stories make
them understand what they're doing
and we often think that we're annoying
people right
whereas
a week ago can you remember what you had
for breakfast last Wednesday I don't and
I probably won't remember that person
who sent me a sales message last
Wednesday either so we're building
familiarity and that's the one thing
I've learned to get people over that
fear of the sales and then they will
become successful
yeah on that
I want to dig a bit deeper on that in a
second but what just quickly what what
was your what was your worst day what
was the the hardest day as a temp
educational recruiter or maybe even
leader like what what was the the worst
day that
you probably had those ideas of maybe
quitting or leaving the industry
I think sometimes it's a stigma that's
attached to you as a recruiter of being
dishonest and I've had that once as a
Rector wreck
and wants as a temp recruiter when a
school was said you were lying to me
this ta is not great she's all you know
it's when you make that mistake and
someone thinks that you're trying to con
them in some way
um that's really hard because for me as
a person and I think any recruiter
should have integrity and should want to
do it for the right reasons
unfortunately the recruitment industry
does have that stigma of
Cutthroat trying to sell me something
and it doesn't have to be like that and
I think that that really hurts me
genuinely hurts me people won't turn up
you'll have bad days placements won't
happen
but for me that's a good day right
because that is when my competitor is
going to quit and I genuinely believe
that like in rectorac I started out I
did 100 calls a day tried to contact
candidates and was like I'm not
interested please stop contacting me I'm
not interested and I thought
what am I doing what did I do why did I
leave employment and then I just thought
to myself no because this is when people
do give up and this is actually when I
have to carry on and I often feel you
have to reach that really bad day
to pick yourself up and that's when the
success comes that's interesting so the
when I said the worst day it was when
you almost felt
I don't want to say attacked but like
your sort of character or actually as a
person was sort of questioned yeah yeah
that that's hard to to swallow yeah I
get that
just on I'm speaking I've spoke to a lot
of recruitment leaders recently
and
I think what's fair to say may not be
for everyone's
um Market but I think over the last read
six months it's definitely become more
difficult
on the business development side for a
lot of the recruiters that I'm speaking
to I think over the last two years a lot
of recruitment companies hired to keep
up with demand
and what would typically happen won't be
the case for everyone but they may have
found themselves starting their
recruitment group in a sort of
candidate-focused role delivery
consultant role resource a role whatever
um maybe we're working on house accounts
key accounts that the the company had
and maybe they did do some business
development but it was quite easy maybe
or they didn't they sort of got a
success maybe quite quickly
but I think that that might have really
shifted for people over the last three
to six months other people I'm speaking
to anyway so I think more and more
recruitment companies are looking at
their teams and going we need more
people to be self-sufficient at winning
their business when the new logos um and
doing that
uh but that's hard and a lot of people
do have that fear that you're talking
about don't want to make the sales calls
don't want to do the best development so
a lot of recruitment leaders have shared
with me because I'm speaking about
learning development and unlocking the
potential of their teams that they that
is something they're always trying to
work with their team on and they really
feel like and I definitely agree a big
part of it is the mindset and a big part
of it is putting clients on a pedestal
um not sort of valuing your own time or
the thinking that your time like they
should give you time right
so you mentioned that earlier I'd love
to just get a bit more on that on your
own experiences of helping your team
become more self-sufficient at BD and
doing more
of the new business generating building
that pipeline when a lot of people are
fearful of it a lot of people have that
mental block how did you help people
break through that
well as I said to you quite honestly I
don't think I did it very well at the
start of my management career
um the superstars were great they were
like yeah we're on the phone but I think
I probably lost a couple of people I
shouldn't have lost
um because I was too task orientated and
I think the thing I've learned is the
environment like actually the lady who
replaced me at axis probably one of the
most positive people I've ever met and
she in many ways has had probably more
success than I have which is okay right
and but I think and I've learned from
her she's very positive and she's if
you're in the right environment that you
don't feel like someone's standing over
you watching you you're going to get
fired any minute then you're gonna be
more inclined to pick up the phone and I
think the reason a lot of people don't
pick up the phone and call people is
because they're insecure within
themselves or they're scared and you
know there's a lot of
as people in general
we focus on the negatives a bit you know
there's that negativity bias
for example I'm sure you speak to more
people on a daily basis about bad
breakups and I'm so happy with my
partner you know you always hear the bad
stories and it's the same with sales
people remember the bad calls but I
think it's at that point you've just
gotta whether it's a prompt whether it's
like a nice song that you listen to
before you do it or something that
motivates you but then afterwards award
just the fact that you've done it is a
great thing and often people don't
realize that the fact that you did that
cool block is so much better because
you've built familiarity so you don't
want to be coming away from we've got
nothing I don't know the fact you got on
the phone is awesome you've built the
familiarity you've built the brand but
the main thing is that people think that
they have to get something from every
call and then they take it too far
Hisham will get annoyed and say don't
call me again salesperson never wants to
make another sales call but actually if
they go more down the route of you're
not interested that's absolutely fine no
problem remember me when you are I'm off
just leave them alone they're not
interest I remember it's a bad day just
go call the next one you know don't nag
people you just want to get a yes no or
maybe as quick as possible and if it's a
yes then you can build on that get in
front of them but don't try and don't
try and push them anywhere that they
don't want to go I think that's the
problem people think that you have to
you don't yeah yeah I definitely
resonate with the focusing on the
outcome rather than the process
so just on that
when you uh what if you were to go back
and work with your recruiters again with
what you know
let's say I was someone that was yeah
did have like a lot of rejection I was I
didn't want to experience that again
um but I do have a cool Black Block I'm
about to do BBD like what what would you
what would your advice be to me to to
focus on the process and like what does
what is the purpose of that call what
what is the what what is actually the
what makes that course successful is it
just information gathering is it I don't
know what how would you like reframe
what that what a successful core block
looks like what is it that
um people should actually be focusing on
rather than yeah getting time signed
with someone or getting a yes like I
don't know what what is it instead that
you'd get them to to focus on I think
first of all having a cool objective
right so a lot of the time you hear
recruiter saying do you need any staff
do you need any staff do you need any
staff
and he's like oh my gosh the amount of
times like recruiters do this and it's
just like it's so destroying whereas if
they talk about a specific member of
Staff which we call a spec or whatever
where you get actually genuinely excited
by this person
um that's going to have more of an
impact I think getting in front of them
building that familiarity like you know
you've basically got about 30 to 60
seconds to make an impact you're not
gonna like so your whole company and
sign terms over the phone but use it as
a chance to get in front of them get a
visit don't ask them when they're free
because no one knows when they're free
we're all so busy so you know what time
um if I was a free Tuesday next week
does 2 p.m or 4pm work for you easy they
can just think 15 minutes oh yeah I can
do that that's fine awesome done then
you've got the chance to build a
relationship with them talk to them a
bit further about what their needs are
so my main bit of advice would be to
not be too transactional in the sense of
I've used that a lot
um that phrase but I think have a
purpose for the call right if it is a
gatekeeper get information then great we
love Gatekeepers like find out exactly
how often you can use it off they often
aren't cool you know get them on site
what do you think so because I don't
want to be annoying and lots of sales
people don't say this people just think
salesperson's annoying
the last thing I want to do is like
um however I have got this really good
candidate I know would be ideal for your
school what do you recommend I do and
get that gatekeep to kind of give you
advice
um and to say why you're calling right
even if even if we were like just
finishing podcasts and your partner
could you like yep what's up why you
know even the people we love the most we
want to know quickly why they're calling
so when it's a stranger
she's got to make a quick impact quickly
and get to the point
yeah I think my insights on my
experience and I'm always on the ongoing
journey of how can improving on on sales
but I think I don't know if if you were
listening to this and maybe relate to
some of this for me I think one of the
best things you can do is write down
what that reason for calling is you
might have a bit of a script or talking
tracks because I think again it comes
down to like you don't when you're doing
those calls you don't want to be
thinking on the spot all the time like
you want to try and make it as easy as
possible
how much really helped me is yeah having
um a bit of a script and explaining like
once when when Susanna does say like why
are you calling me that you've got a
succinct answer that you've experimented
and tested and you can try out different
things that you use and you can
obviously sense you know what that
worked really well that didn't I'm going
to change that but I think definitely
going into these types of calls equipped
with what is it that I'm gonna say
Obviously you are gonna have to think on
your feet you are going to have to react
and that's what makes great sales people
but I think like there will be parts
that you can um yeah practice and have a
bit of a script and I think the other
breakthrough that I've had is
I I always recommend this book for
anyone if you're listening to this
you're probably into your own learning
development but if you have you read the
um never split the difference
oh yeah that's like you have to read
that so for me that is the best
negotiation sales book in in my view
never split the difference never split
the difference Chris Voss uh he was a um
FBI uh hostage negotiator for X number
of years and then he's taken everything
that they applied in that context to
sales to the commercial world and you
can use it in so many different things
but one of the biggest breakthroughs
just really quickly and then we'll move
on is that the power of no questions I
don't know if you've come across this
no but I'm so curious so what I've so
when I don't know what you think about
this we can just play this out but how
do you feel when you say yes
good good
maybe let me give it to this how when
you're in this when you're being sold to
or the context or getting a call you
didn't expect it
how do you how do you feel about saying
yes in in that context
bit guarded
right so for me I feel like what am I
letting myself in for yeah a bit like
what what is this now what's the what's
the catch exactly so the biggest
breakthrough that I've had is is it's
all about leading with no questions and
what I mean by that and from reading
this book and I use it every single day
is when you when you have when the other
person is saying no they almost feel in
control
they feel empowered because when you say
you'll you'll see you're saying no and
then it's like you can justify why
you're saying no whatever like you do
feel in control rather than saying yes
so just a just a quick tip every single
call that I start I start with the same
uh question and it works really well and
it's starting with a note rather than
getting a yes and then and the answer is
are you in the middle of something
and I'm either gonna get no I'm not
which then gives me the opportunity to
carry on the conversation or if I get
yes that's fine they've said yes I am
really busy and it's like okay well sure
when there's a better time or whatever
but if they say no they felt in control
and they're like no I'm not I'm not busy
and then you've then uh it then leads
into the conversation but again the the
other tip and the way to use this as
well is
when you're let's say you get the Y
like so for me it's all about uncovering
does this person have the problems I
think they may have that's what I want
to find out
so I will outlay so let's say it's a
school is like I speak to educational
leaders all the time who share with me
that they have the attempt show up late
or the quality of the the attempts
aren't great from the people that I was
speaking to
etc etc and then you go but you're
probably going to tell me that none of
that resonates you go no no no that is
that is definitely true do you get what
I mean so it's it's it's the yeah I
would definitely look into that and when
we're talking about sales and getting
more out of your conversations no
questions is is big I love that can I
just ask you a genuine after I get to
ask you a question yeah of course so how
do you
say you're contacting your friends or
your colleagues how do you like to be
contacted the most like what's your your
WhatsApp are you texting you phone
which one are you like what's your main
communication source of communicating
with your your colleagues and brands
I'd say I'd say WhatsApp but I do I
prefer I prefer having a conversation
yeah the reason I ask this is because I
know I've spoken a lot about picking up
the phone
um but now like for example I put
everyone into a sequence right so I will
always pick up the phone first but then
I maybe will wait four days and I'll
send a voice note on LinkedIn and I
should stop telling people about this
because it's probably been one of the
most successful things that I've done
voice notes on LinkedIn no one's doing
it and like video messages videard again
people aren't doing it but the open rate
is so much higher than the messages so I
put people into a sequence so I do
telephone call wait four days voice note
eight four days message wait four days
email and often I get a response whereas
if I just stuck to one communication
method just phoning it would probably
fall a bit more in deaf ears there might
not be a phone person they might prefer
email
and you know sometimes I think as
salespeople we forget we'd stick with
what we're comfortable like I spend so
many consultants like I'm good on visits
okay awesome but you know what about the
people who don't really meet people you
know there's all sorts of ways and we've
got so much at our disposal and a lot of
people are not
um flexing their communication enough
and I think that's been a really big
kind of aha moment for me and something
that we don't realize that we're not
doing enough we're just sticking to one
communication style that is our
preference not the people we want to
reach that's a great Insight
particularly on again we're talking
about BD sales getting more out of it
plaster the candidate side as well but
yeah I'm I'm big on this with um done a
couple of sessions recently on
recruitment mentors about you're having
a multi-channel approach Landing that
first client meeting and yeah for me the
best recruiters uh do have different
ways and different ways they use all
different ways of communicating so like
yourself and this is what you can
experiment with everyone and this is the
fun part about it but for me if I want
to take Susanna who I think is my ideal
customer profile yeah I take her through
a journey where it starts with an email
then it's a phone call then it's a
LinkedIn voice note then it's another
um email then it's a phone call so yeah
100 experience like testing and using
different ways to communicate with
people is absolutely what you should be
doing if you're just following up every
couple of days by trying to phone them
yeah you might get limited results and
and limited success and what you just
said as well about the right client
making sure it's the right the clients
that are going to be your best clients
opposed to wasting time with clients who
might never use anyway I'm wondering why
you're not getting any success
so what what's been your biggest
challenge like I feel like I it does
come up a lot where sometimes like you
do have a lot of people that do rhetoric
that I'll be honest are a bit similar to
where it's it's a it's a it's a
one-person band
just smashing it out making however much
money a year and that's fine but I think
a lot of people feel like it's easy or
easy to do because it's like I know what
I'm going to stop my own recruitment
business rhetoric I've done recruiting
myself I'm gonna do that and I think
there's only a few it depends what your
goals are but I do think there are only
a few redirect businesses that have
successfully like scaled or grown
because it is really difficult yeah
what's been your biggest challenge since
since going on on this journey because
you obviously was an educational
recruitment you as a leader I'm sure you
recruited for the branches that you're
responsible for but it's entirely
different to then recruit for different
recruitment businesses than having to
deal with recruiters that know how to
sell they know how to to sell themselves
they know the game so what has been your
biggest challenge since on the rec
direct Journey you want to know the
truth
getting over the difficult boring
moments of it right so and what I mean
by that is have you ever read the book
Atomic Habits by just asking it honestly
I I'm actually in love with James Clear
um because it's changed my life that
book and like every night before I go to
bed I I create my 30 names right that's
my 30 names and then I wake up in the
morning I try and wake up about 5 30.
that's my time and then I did the thing
I don't like doing the most in the
morning which is the BT which is the
hunting and that is where I go through
these 30 names and I I approach them in
various different ways you know I eat
that frog thing you don't want to do in
the morning it's not that at 5 30 in the
morning well I I that's my me time I'd
probably start at 7 30. so again do a
video of five phones so wake up at 5 30
I I kind of have my me time and wake up
the kids and then I go to the gym
um and work out and then I because I
work at the gym because they've got a
workspace and then I will do my BDS that
once that's done I've set myself up for
Success it's only like nine o'clock I've
already done my workout I've done my BD
and then I get to do the things that I
enjoy doing a bit more and the reason
that this works so well is because it is
it's a habit did it happen it's like you
know we hope we must brush our teeth
twice a day right is there any effort no
because we just we built the Habit
whereas once upon a time that was
probably it would be difficult if we
started a new habit tomorrow it would be
difficult and we would probably fail and
then maybe think oh it doesn't work I'm
not going to do it again what I've
learned about habits is that the it's
like obstacle immunity right it's an
obstacle at first but the more that you
do it the more you just look to it and
it's just something you just do
um so for me that's been you asked me
why how I've been successful and what
makes it stand out is because I am so
disciplined right even when I'm not
motivated when motivation isn't there
discipline shows up and that's the quote
that I live by and I I literally am so
disciplined to the point that I'm not
happy if that discipline is broken and I
think again talk about strong recruiters
it's the people who can show discipline
when you're working for yourself it's
hard tears I just want to am I in bed
sometimes I just want to watch Netflix
so what your so your biggest challenge
has been
doing the boring stuff yeah like and
making sure that you stick to the habits
right because there's always something
we prefer to be doing and sometimes it's
what you need to do opposed to what you
want to do
what do you believe recruiters want out
of their career what is the most common
thing that you find out so then I want
this in my next role I'm motivated by
this I want this my company has not
giving me this like what is it that
again everyone's different but what are
the common things that you hear from
recruiters when you work with them like
what is it they want so I do find this
different right so as a right to rack
the worst thing you can do I believe is
sell people jobs because I don't know
like I might be like hey Isha I've got a
job that's like the best work-life
balance that you could ever have Haitian
might not want a better work-life
balance you might be all about the money
so my first question is always all right
what's most important to you money work
life balance regression social culture
um
and most of the time people say with all
of them then you ask them to put them in
order right and then a good recruiter
will scenario paint so for example how
many times do recruiters say for example
they went to work in Brighton they told
me they only wanted to work in London
but they've just got a job in Brighton
with another recruiter no no they
definitely wanted to work in London they
definitely want to work in London that's
not true well it did happen they're
working in Brighton but why and often
it's because the recruiter didn't form
scenarios where you said that location
is important to you but what if you got
50 000 pounds would you then move to
Brighton
actually yeah actually London isn't so
important I probably would move to
Brighton so for example a lot of
recruiters they take it as a given what
people say first but give them scenarios
well what if you had more of a work-life
balance but they paid you a bit less
would that be more important to you then
yeah actually it would so I think um a
big kind of the biggest skill that a
recruiter can have is to delve into that
discovery of scenarios because you might
think you know what that person wants
but you don't know until you give them
the scenarios
so when you do that exercise will
recruit is what the top two typically is
it money yeah you got it yeah money and
progression okay everyone wants more
money and especially at the moment I
think a lot there's a lot of people out
there who want as much money as possible
for an easier role as possible so a
company that will provide the most
resources
um but it's the recruiters that will
take those resources and take that money
make something of it that are the
superstars and
some of them I just just I've got a big
heart I just adore them I just think
they're most amazing people I just think
some recruiters that you meet are just
so inspirational and that's why I love
what I do
tell me about from your perspective
where where do where the um whether
typically companies go wrong in keeping
their staff so what are the common
frustrations pains that you hear from
recruiters is it that they work for a
manager who is a proper micromanager or
doesn't Empower them they don't feel
valued is it I haven't had the right
training what's the typical things that
you hear from people when it comes to my
company's not doing this so I want this
like where are companies falling short
you think commonly there's one thing
that comes to mind and it's trust right
so especially with this whole work from
home thing it's caused a lot of politics
in many companies and often because
somebody maybe has
not done a very good job working from
home so as a result the whole team are
not allowed to work from home anymore
and the people are actually quite
trustworthy and work very autonomously
get really frustrated by that
um and I think as a manager one of the
best things that you can do is show
trust to your employees and make them
accountable and not watch them that old
school recruiting of like how many calls
you made today how many calls you made
today
I don't think it works I don't and it's
like I I you get results maybe yes for a
certain amount of time looking at call
time and analyzing it but ultimately
showing them trust it the results will
come out for themselves and the best
companies are the ones are not hiring
and firing but they're the ones who
coach
to understand that actually you know
what this this role isn't for me and the
person makes the decision themselves
instead of on the firing line which
creates fear uncertainty and negativity
in teens
how can you sniff out if a recruitment
company isn't going to trust you
as a recruiter
I think you
've got to ask them how they manage and
you've got to say
um I think you do have to ask around a
bit but also make your own decision go
into the office look at the people do
they really look happy
um what what is the turnover like there
right like one of my best clients that
average person stays there for a minimum
four years which is amazing Recruitment
and their mission statement is are
people matter most and they live and
breathe that and everything they do and
it's a joy to recruit for them because
people see that when they go there so I
think it's um awesome about their
attention if a job's become available it
seems too good to be true ask them how
that job became available and there's
nothing wrong with asking that you need
to know one of the most important
decisions you can make is where you work
so we only get one life right only one
so as as we as we wrap up and finish
this then like what what has
what has surprised you most since going
on this right threat Journey do you
think
it's a good question I think it
surprised me most the amount of people
who
stay perhaps in roles
where they're not treated well because
of fear
um
as a lot of people that I speak to very
regularly I've been speaking to for the
last year who it's really clear that
they could be getting a footpreneur
somewhere else and they're really
unhappy but they just haven't got the
confidence to make that jump so I think
that's one of my biggest surprises
um
is witnessing the people who are almost
blinded by loyalty and
what are the chances of us being alive
right one in Australian is it something
and you know there's such an important
thing like we do want to get one life
and it's like you spend more time at
work than you do with your family so if
if there are things that are
consistently making you unhappy if
you're worried about going to work every
Sunday and you're dreading the Monday
then something's not right and I think
that my biggest surprising moment is
that people could
take that and make the right changes
so let's wrap this up then with
obviously so you specifically focus on
education and Professional Services
right that's what you've been focusing
on so how would you how would you
describe the market right now
exactly what you said I think it's been
a great time to be a recruiter over the
last year and I think now is the time
when people have to upskill companies
have to invest in their in in the BD
side of it because you're going to have
to start working harder to get on the
clients but also look at your branding
you know speak speak to yourself like
really look at what is your mission
go away from being transactional start
thinking about what bring heart back to
Recruitment and less making a placement
for the sake of it
but found
what good I know everyone's different
like different marks and everything but
overall are you feeling in terms of the
clients that you work with are they
seeing a massive slowdown are they not
are they seeing that it's sort of just
adjusting to maybe what normal would be
compared to that what it has been like
how do you describe those markets out of
Interest I think people are becoming
fussier with the standard
um they want to see proof of Billings
they want to really
UM Vet their candidates in the best
possible way people are still recruiting
but they're more
um like for example cross sector
recruitment isn't happening as much
period people are wanting to see pay
slips for evidence then wanting to see
proof of Billings
um they're delving into a deeper
interview process and so they should
right it's a big decision
Susanna thanks for uh joining the
podcast love your journey love your
mindset uh massive thank you for for
joining me absolute pleasure have a
great thank you thank you so much for
listening to the episode I hope you got
value from the conversation and you had
a number of key takeaways if you did
enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode